Привіт, привіт! Я Ольга Дудар.
Я вчителька, викладачка, дослідниця.
І ми з вами продовжуємо наш
екскурс в минуле України.
Сьогодні ми з вами
проаналізуємо такі питання.
Перше. Ми поговоримо про створення
Автономної Республіки Крим.
Проаналізуємо Декларацію
про державний суверенітет.
Пригадаємо, завдяки свідченням
очевидців, учасників подій –
«Революцію на граніті» і
дуже коротко окреслимо спробу
державного перевороту в Радянському
Союзі у серпні 1991 року.
І традиційно ми почнемо
з домашнього завдання,
із перевірки ваших знань.
Для перевірки ваших знань я
скористаюсь форматом тестів
зовнішнього незалежного оцінювання.
І традиційноми почнемо
з домашнього завдання.
Перш ніж ми розглянемо те
питання, яке я пропонувала вам
опрацювати самостійно, давайте
зробимо такий невеличкий тест
у форматі зовнішнього незалежного
оцінювання з історії України.
Буде кілька завдань (якщо ви
і правда збираєтесь складати
саме це зовнішнє незалежне оцінювання),
де з семи варіантів відповіді
ви маєте обрати три правильних.
Отже, зверніть, будь
ласка, увагу на питання:
«Які події відбулися
раніше за аварію на ЧАЕС?».
Якщо у вас гарна пам'ять
і ви чітко пам'ятаєте дати,
таке завдання ви виконаєте з легкістю.
Але не всі ми можемо тримати
в пам'яті велику кількість дат,
тому можемо використовувати
логіку подій,
але для цього треба дійсно
гарно пам'ятати матеріал.
Отже, давайте подивимось
на правильну відповідь, як:
«Проголошення курсу реформ,
який отримав назву перебудова»,
«Початок антиалкогольної кампанії»
та «Підтвердження
курсу на «прискорення».
І зверніть, будь ласка, увагу.
Отже, до квітня 1986
року було започатковано
«перебудову»
- ну, це логічно.
Початок антиалкогольної кампанії
- це одна із спроб
реформувати життя, оскільки
проблема зловживання алкоголем
була суттєвою і таким чином
дисциплінувати громадян,
показати прагнення до
дійсних реальних змін –
це доволі неочікувані
наслідки отримала ця кампанія,
але вона якраз 1985 рік.
І в лютому 1986 року було
підтверджено курс на «прискорення»,
тобто розширення повноважень
підприємствщодо їхньої діяльності,
заохочення тих працівників,
які краще працювали - такі зміни,
які начебто мали покращити
економічне життя, але насправді,
з іншого боку, не дуже суттєво впливали
на економічну систему Радянського Союзу.
Всі інші події, як ви
бачите, відбулися пізніше.
Часто, коли йдеться про часи перебудови,
використовують карикатури,
які, насправді, доволі в'їдливо
характеризували дуже актуальні
питання життя Радянського Союзу.
І от перед вами карикатура
про «прискорення»
(так, ми вже про нього говорили) і
підпис «Наш главк теж набирає обертів».
Насправді, дуже часто «прискорення»
- його ефективність
знижувалася тим, що підприємства,
замість обіцяної економічної свободи,
отримували величезну
купу директив і вказівок,
що не полегшувало процес
виробництва, а набагато ускладнювало,
і оця бюрократизація,
насправді, меншою не ставала.
І я просила вас поміркувати
над тим, які фактори утруднювали
культурне життя і культурний
розвиток УРСР в часи перебудови?
І я для себе на перше місце
визначила все-таки русифікацію,
через те, що російськомовний
контент користувався більшою
популярністю і це була цілеспрямована
політика радянської влади.
Негативно впливає
загострення економічної кризи.
Якщо почитати свідків
подій, то вони говорять,
що обираючи між походом в
театр чи в музей і вирішенням
повсякденних питань, люди,
звичайно що, витрачати кошти
на свої буденні потреби.
І тиск влади на ті сфери культури,
які демонстрували наростання
отаких от опозиційних
настроїв і незадоволення
існуючим станом справ
у Радянському Союзі.
Це могли бути і сфери культури,
це могли бути і окремі діячі,
яких можна назвати, як зараз
по-сучасному - лідерами думок,
позиція яких, насправді,
впливала на багатьох.
Ну і розпочнемо роботу з новим
матеріалом теж з повторення.
Пригадайте, будь ласка,
коли в Радянському Союзі
було проведено депортацію
кримськотатарського народу?
Я сподіваюсь, вине забули, що це
- травень 1944 року
і це жахлива трагедія і для
кримськотатарського народу,
і для історії модерної
України в тому числі.
Ситуація в період перебудови
складалась доволі особлива.
Москва вирішила підтримати
прагнення представників
політичної номенклатури Криму,
скористатися змінами в державі
і отримати особливий статус, а
можливо, і виокремитися від УРСР.
В листопаді 1989 року Верховна
Рада СРСР ухвалила постанову
(я зачитаю) «Про висновки і
пропозиції комісії з проблем
радянських німців
ікримськотатарського народу».
Використовуючи інтереси
народів, які проживали в Криму,
і забуваючи про інтереси
українців, які проживали в Криму,
рекомендували створити
Кримську Автономну Радянську
Соціалістичну Республіку у
складі Радянської України.
Російська більшість, якщо ми
не зважаємо на кількість татар
і на кількість українців, яких не
об'єднували в єдине поле інтересу,
побачила в цьому шанс
таким чином унезалежнитися
від Москви і від Києва.
Було піднято питання – а як
же ж змінити статус Криму?
І таким чином вирішили
провести референдум,
який би підтвердив позицію,
скажімо так, місцевих жителів.
Зважаючи на реалії, коли
організовували референдум,
то розраховували на
його позитивні наслідки,
якими можна скористатися в
своїй політичній діяльності.
Для того, щоб провести референдум,
було в листопаді 1990 року
схвалено Декларацію про
державний і правовий статус Криму,
в якій йшлося про те, що
постанови і рішення 45-46 років
ліквідувати Кримську Автономну
Радянську Соціалістичну Республіку
були неконструктивними і
необхідно відновити права Криму,
як суб'єкту Радянського Союзу і учасника
майбутнього Союзного договору.
І саме для цього було
проведено референдум.
Зверніть, будь ласка, увагу
на результати референдуму.
Оскільки питання було
сформульовано відповідним чином:
«Чи ви підтримуєте відтворення
Кримської Автономної
Радянської Соціалістичної Республіки,
як суб'єкта Радянського Союзу
і як учасника Союзного
договору» під впливом
і місцевих партійних еліт, і
найперше, під впливом Москви,
більшість жителів Криму, ті
хто брали участь у референдумі,
підтримали таке рішення.
Але насправді, вся історія
з проголошенням автономії,
якщо ми говоримо про етап референдуму,
підтримувалася із Москви з єдиною метою
- для того,
щоб утруднити вихід України
зі складу Радянського Союзу.
І це надзвичайно складне
питання, тому що виникає таке от
певне здивування, адже
перебудова – це, насамперед,
курс на певний ідеологічний
злам, на відмову від монополії
комуністичної партіїна владу,
на реальну демократизацію.
Але на практиці ми бачимо
зовсім інші процеси,
які не сприяли демократизації.
Можна назвати це політичними
інтригами, які, в принципі,
суттєво ускладнювали
політичне життя в Україні.
Після референдуму українська
комуністична верхівка,
яку ми не можемо назвати
державницькою елітою,
вирішила відреагувати
по-своєму і дуже швидко –
для того, щоб це питання
зняти і зняти його таким чином,
щоб не вступити в конфлікт
прямий із всесоюзним керівництвом,
не вступити в конфлікт з Москвою,
але і зберегти Крим у складі УРСР,
і певним чином зняти напругу.
Не зустрічаючись ні з
представниками українців у Криму,
ні з делегацією
Центральної Ради Організації
кримськотатарського національного руху,
Верховна Рада УРСР 12 лютого
1991 року ухвалила закон,
яким в межах Кримської
області було відновлено
Кримську Автономну Радянську
Соціалістичну Республіку в межах УРСР.
Тобто це було не дуже
логічно і це стало основою
для подальших конфліктів і для цієї
ситуації, яка склалась в Україні нині.
Після перших виборів
до Верховної РадиУРСР,
які мали певну альтернативу,
у Верховній Раді,
я співаюсь ви це
пам'ятаєте, було два блоки:
блок «За суверенну
Радянську Україну» на чолі
з Олександром Морозом і «Народна
Рада» на чолі з Юхновським.
У них були різні погляди
щодо майбутнього України
і, в принципі, це суттєво
впливало на внутрішню політику.
Проте постає питання суверенітету.
І воно стало актуальнішим, на жаль,
не у зв'язку з внутрішніми
змінами в Україні.
І давайте пригадаємо
- що таке суверенітет.
Суверенітет - це юридичний термін,
який означає повноту
і неподільність влади всередині держави
і незалежність її у зовнішній політиці.
Так-от питання суверенітету
постало через події,
які відбувались у Москві.
Коли Горбачова у 1990 році обрали
Президентом Радянського Союзу,
він зміцнив своє становище в державі.
Але коли було скасовано 6-ту
статтю Конституції Радянського Союзу
про керівну роль комуністичної
партії, цим скористалися
його опоненти на чолі
з Борисом Єльциним.
У червні 1990 року, з
ініціативи Бориса Єльцина,
було ухвалено Декларацію
про державний суверенітет
Російської Радянської Федеративної
Соціалістичної Республіки.
Українські політики незалежницького
формату були натхненні
прикладом Росії і це мотивувало
їх до історичного кроку.
16 липня 1990 року в
Україні було проголошено
Декларацію про державний
суверенітет України і це було
першим кроком до формування
ідеї незалежності України.
Після цього Голова Верховної
Ради УРСР Івашко подав у відставку
і реальні шанси стати Головою
Верховної Ради отримав тоді
теж впливовий політик Леонід Кравчук.
В цей часкомуністична
партія України, насправді,
залишалася складовою, такою
дисциплінованою частинкою
комуністичної партії Радянського
Союзу і все рівно зважала
на ті процеси, які відбувались в Москві.
Що могло змусити їх
змінювати свою думку?
Давайте поміркуємо.
Але перш ніж ми дамо
відповідь на це питання,
давайте звернемо увагу на текст
Декларації про державний суверенітет.
Отже, на що звертала увагу, що
проголошувала Верховна Рада УРСР?
Що вона прагне створити
демократичне суспільство,
прагне забезпечувати
права і свободи людини,
шанувати національні права всіх народів,
дбати про повноцінний
розвиток і проголошує
державний суверенітет України,
як верховенство, самостійність,
повноту і неподільність
влади в республіці.
Було зазначено дуже важливий
юридичний принцип і бажано було б,
звичайно, щоб він в майбутньому
втілювався на практиці.
Проте, насправді, ситуація
мало змінювалася і навіть,
не зважаючи на масштабні
мітинги, коли люди величезною
кількістю виходили на вулиці,
коли вимагали демократизації,
коли виступали проти Союзного
договору, проти реформування
такого уявного,
насправді,Радянського Союзу,
потрібний був крок, який би мотивував
суспільство і показав би владі,
показав би оцій комуністичній
верхівці, що треба змінюватися.
І такою іскрою, і дуже важливим
кроком в поширенні, в популяризації,
в формуванні ідеї
незалежності в широкому загалі
можна вважати «Революцію на граніті».
Для того, щоб поговорити
про ці події, я скористалась
таким принципом дослідження,
як історичне інтерв'ю.
Я говорила з одним із
учасників голодування.
І які цікаві особливості, те,
про що розповів учасник подій.
По-перше, всі учасники голодування
мали певний досвід боротьби
за права студентів і маючи
безпосередні контакти з керівництвом,
вони все більше стверджувалися
в ідеї, що без незалежної України
не буде ніяких змін позитивних,
які вони хотіли досягти.
В організації «Революції
на граніті» брали участь
кілька груп студентів із
Києва, з Дніпра, зі Львова.
Це «Студентське братство», це
«Українська студентська спілка».
І вони абсолютно свідомо розуміли
- з якими труднощами
їм доведеться зіткнутися.
Які були вимоги? Чого хотіли ті,
хто потім вийдуть і будуть тримати
доволі важке голодування?
По-перше, припинити
повноваження Верховної Ради УРСР
і провести нові вибори на
багатопартійних засадах.
Оскільки з 90-го року ситуація
змінювалася
і формується багатопартійність,
і все-таки популяризуються ті,
хто заявляє про необхідність
незалежності України, студенти
розраховували, що нові вибори
істотно і якісно змінять
склад Верховної Ради УРСР.
Ухвалити закон про націоналізацію
майна комуністичної партії
і підлеглих їй структур.
Не допуститипідписання оцього
Союзного договору, який, в принципі,
це окрема тема для розмови
i ми поговоримо про це
на наступному уроці детальніше,
але Союзний договір не передбачав,
насправді, демократичного
реформування Радянського Союзу,
а просто формальне переформатування.
Плюс львівські студенти
вимагали додати до цієї вимоги
теж дуже важливу суттєву
- щоб громадяни УРСР не проходили
військову службу в інших
союзних республіках.
Це дуже важлива риса чому?
Якщо представники інших союзних
республік служили на території УРСР,
це давало шанс скористатися
ними як великою силою
для придушення виступів в Україні.
І теж була вимога відправити у відставку
Голову Ради Міністрів УРСР Масола.
Я дуже вдячна Едуарду
Станіславовичу Шевельову
за те, що він поділився спогадами.
Студенти, які голодували в жовтні,
насправді, для мене героїчні люди,
тому що треба було
домовитись і розрахувати.
Вони знали, що в їхньому
середовищі є ті, хто повідомить
владні органи про масштаби акції
і, в принципі, до цього готувались.
От коли я спитала у пана Едуарда,
який його такий найяскравішийспогад
про «Революцію на граніті»,
- те що він згадав найперше, і те,
що він називав вже в інших інтерв'ю
- коли вони в гуртожитку
філософського факультету
(зараз це Київський національний
університет імені Тараса
Григоровича Шевченка),
одягали білі смужки на рукави ті,
хто погоджувався на голодування
і це був такий процес … (це всі
молоді студенти) … з жартами,
але потім стало зрозуміло, що
це, насправді, дуже серйозна акція
і є певна відповідальність,
і є певні перестороги.
Окрім більше ста, точно цифра
зараз, напевно, що невідома,
і навіть учасникам подій, окрім
тих студентів, які голодували,
була велика кількість, які
підтримували їх морально,
які здійснювали охорону табору,
які підтримували порядок.
Люди, учасники цієї акції, вірили,
що такий безпрецедентний хід,
він приверне увагу всього
суспільства до тих важливих питань
і покаже, що молодь,
насправді, хоче якісних змін.
Я питала у пана Едуарда чи були
якісь провокації, чи, наприклад,
була якась загроза студентам,
які розташувалися тоді
на Жовтневій площі (зараз це
Майдан Незалежності в Києві).
Він не назвав мені ніяких
прикладів, але говорив:
що родичі,друзі голодуючих
повідомляли, що в регіонах України
проводили збори трудових
колективів, проводили виховні бесіди
із студентами, де пояснювали,
що ось ці голодуючі –
вони ж не організовувалися самі по собі,
що в них є якісь дорослі
досвідчені керівники або що ними,
найгірше, керує рука капіталізму.
Все робилося для того, щоб
цю акцію дискредитувати.
Оскільки загострювалася
економічна криза,
оскільки ідея незалежності
здобуває популярність,
то і багато людей, хто знали
студентів, розуміли що це все неправда.
Емпатія, співчуття голодуючим зростало.
В табір голодуючих
проходив Леонід Кравчук,
але компромісу досягти
не вдалося і врешті-решт –
влада то погодилась на вимоги студентів,
але реально в такому масштабі,
як студенти цього хотіли,
вдалося добитися лише відставки Масола.
Зі свідчень пана Едуарда я знаю,
що початок акції був анонсований
на 1 жовтня для того,
щоб дезорієнтувати владу.
Насправді зараз, зважаючи
на досвід незалежної України,
у нас може скластися враження,
що організувати таку акцію,
такий протестбуло доволі
просто, і що студенти нічим
окрім власного здоров'я (ну витримати
голодування з 2 до 17 жовтня,
це, насправді, дуже важко і
виснажливо), але що окрім втрат
для здоров'я
- вони нічим не ризикували.
Всі попередні акції
- перші, наприклад, мітинги у Львові,
вони … теж люди-учасники
всіх цих подій - вони писали,
що острах був, бо невідомо чим
все закінчиться і чи не буде це
стаття кримінального кодексу,
і якийсь дуже суворий вирок.
Чому влада не так жорстко
поставилась до цього
студентського голодування?
Це доволі дискусійне питання
і я зараз скажу свою думку
(ви можете, зважаючи на матеріали
підручника, зважаючи на те,
і я вас закликаю прочитати про
«Революцію на граніті» додатково),
студентські рухи, насправді,
- це дуже важливий маркер.
Не лише в Радянському
Союзі, а й в інших країнах.
Якщо студенти піднімаються
і активно долучаються
до політичної боротьби, для
влади це має бути такий сигнал,
що все, що ви робите
- неправильно і треба дійсно
запроваджувати якісь якісні зміни.
Можливо і для Кравчука, і
для його оточення було важливо
досягти певної домовленості, не
довести до ескалації конфлікту
для того, щоб не втратити певний імідж.
Крім того, ті процеси, які
відбувалися і в Москві, адже боротьба
між Горбачовим і боротьба між
Єльциним тривала, і, напевно,
партійна верхівка не орієнтувалася
- хто вийде переможцем.
Крім того, існували ще третя сила
- це реакційна частинка
комуністичної партії.
І в неї були прихильники серед
простих громадян, які, в принципі
(ну це ж для мене, наприклад,
дуже дивно), у яких була ностальгія
за часами, коли все було
жорсткіше, коли не було гласності,
коли навіть та інформація, яка
з'явилася про важливі історичні події, -
то краще б вона не
з'являлася, бо це дуже змінює
політичну ситуацію в країні.
Тому безперечно і ті, хто голодували,
і ті, хто їх підтримували –
це герої незалежної України.
Це люди, які одними із перших
відкрито і в протистоянні
з владою підняли питання,
- а чи існуватиме
українська незалежна держава
і намагалися продемонструвати
суспільству, що є достатньо
велика кількість молодих людей–
відважних, сильних, рішучих,
які готові різними методами
боротися за ось цю незалежність України.
18 серпня 1991 року Михайло
Горбачов був блокований
на дачі у Форосі в Криму і радянські
телеглядачі побачили картинку
їм знайому, коли замість
новин і звичних телепередач,
демонстрували балет і
концерт класичної музики.
Зазвичай це було таким знаком,
що помер Генеральний Секретар.
Але ішлось про зовсім інше, про спробу
державного перевороту
в Радянському Союзі.
Вранці19 серпня телерадіоканали
і засоби масової інформації
передали повідомлення з Москви
про створення нового органу –
державного комітету
з надзвичайного стану
(російською мовою це
буде абревіатура ГКЧП),
і про звернення учасників цієї
нової структури до громадян.
До неї входили доволі впливові
політики - це віце-президент
Радянського Союзу Геннадій
Янаєв, прем'єр-міністр Радянського
Союзу Валентин Павлов,
голова КДБ Володимир Крючков,
міністр оборони Дмитро Язов.
Тобтолюди, які мали реальний вплив
на здійснення влади в Радянському Союзі.
У зверненні вони оголосили про
введення надзвичайного стану
в деяких районах Радянського
Союзу і про припинення
виходу більшості засобів
масової інформації в світ.
Також Янаєв заявив, що Горбачов нібито
хворий і він бере обов'язки на себе.
Вранці 19 серпня 1991 року
до Леоніда Кравчука прийшов
командувач сухопутних військ
СРСР генерал Варєнніков
у супроводі першого секретаря ЦК
КПУГуренка і місцевих генералів.
І вони озвучили десь
приблизно такі вимоги:
що в західних областях має
бути введений надзвичайний стан;
необхідно заборонити страйки;
призупинити діяльність всіх партій
крім комуністичної, і припинити
діяльність газет цих партій;
розганяти мітинги; треба
провести екстрені заходи,
які б продемонстрували, що влада
в Україні не йде старим курсом,
тобто курсом перебудови; війська
приведені до бойової готовності
і можуть бути застосовані.
В той момент Кравчук і його
оточення не мали такої можливості
вступити в силове протистояння,
але вони намагалися
хитро вичікувати -що
відбудеться в Москві.
Коли стало зрозуміло, що 20
серпня в Москві перемагають
прихильники Єльцина і
путч буде неуспішним,
було оприлюднено заяву
Президії Верховної Ради України,
УРСР тоді, в якій постанова
путчистів не визнавалась.
Але є такий важливий
момент, щоб ви розуміли,
що насправді, були прихильники
і повернення до старих методів
керівництва, що контрольовані
компартією України обласні комітети
в деяких областях визнали
рішення і дії ГКЧП,
причому без будь-якого
на нихсилового тиску.
Але події серпня
- вони стали дуже важливим каталізатором
всіх процесів, які призвели
до незалежності України.
Але детальніше ми про це поговоримо
з вами на наступному уроці.
І я дуже попрошу вас
уважно, ретельно прочитати
матеріал підручника, визначити
для себе важливі базові моменти,
можливо, ви навіть випишете кілька дат.
Я рекомендую вам запам'ятати
- коли було проголошено
Декларацію про державний суверенітет
і коли відбувся путч ГКЧП.
І крім того - чи погоджуєтеся ви
з моїм висновком про те,
що путч реакційних сил став тим важелем,
який зробив незворотнім
процес в напрямку
проголошення незалежності України.
І попрошу вас звернути
увагу на підписи на плакатах
під час «Революції на граніті».
Зафіксуйте їх собі, будь
ласка, і спробуйте пояснити –
що мали на увазі учасники
голодування і ті, хто їх підтримували,
коли говорили, що: «Наше
ярмо:  239, КДБ, КПУ»,
чому «Комуністам –
комунізм, Україні – свободу»
і чому КПРС треба було б
відправити на смітник історії.
Ці події дуже важливі і
хоча вони трошки віддалені
в часі від вас і від мене, але
вони вплинули і впливають надалі
на сучасний політичний розвиток України.
Тому будьте допитливі, будьте критичні,
не бійтесь робити власні висновки.
До наступного уроку.